yeah welcome to this video playing zone
you some or whatever yeah let's see what
we get an Italian game let's play the
two nuts Queenie too well this is really
early what is the idea Bishop c5 and
take on a sub node hmm yeah but it's not
really working right person can take I
can play d 5 so it's just an Italian
game with an early Queenie too okay if I
was curious but I thought you would
would try to play for long castles but
it doesn't seem to be the case and
should i go d5 yeah maybe take this
chance to get this free move in
sometimes hear you don't manage
yeah this looks some fairly solid Joe I
don't want to have a bishop really and
here well should should I take the good
question come on this is just easy easy
to play like basically a pawn up now
because of his his doubled pawns yeah it
seems like he wants to play Knight age
42 f five but I can just play g6 here by
th for just g6 and it's completely
useless Queen g5 probably not a three
what he needs to do this anyway okay you
tell that some fries here
hmm look g3 coming on
hmm okay I'm so I should have played
Queen g5 nevertheless this is a really
really problematic now just 96
threatening
got into it the night is saying on top
of all of that great Wow
oh yeah I don't have a move it's just
losing what can you do
you had the worst thing is it is amazing
it's not not many ways to go wrong here
can maybe 96 for something I can maybe
manage that no this is this is the way
to go all night h3 at the rook is saying
g3 is really a lemon am I getting I'm
getting on the exchange back so just
take it down okay so i can i can even
click winner 7 that sir it's not bad but
okay just just go here
so what is the Sonoma pond on yo
23 is my idea attacking the four-pound
at the c-4 point now this is a text a
for mercy for gases probably probably
about equal don't think that is extra
policy is of any meaning here okay can
imply code reform
chattering Queenie too if it goes 25 or
something
queen age too
check
Queen trade is just dead wrong okay i'll
draw divine job draw declined draw draw
fine oh god yeah you've got one of those
guys
check gras Harford
game drawn yeah we can easily make the
50 moves in 30 seconds even yeah of
course this was really wow I was
completely completely ignoring what he
was doing I mean yeah yeah I think black
cannot possibly be worse I mean it's
hard to imagine of course f6 g6 is
somewhat weak but still I mean I'm
basically porn up because of the after
the double pawns played this time I need
some precise moves here rocket III yeah
of course rocket III simply preventing
on yeah it prevents in Rocky III Rocky
III is good that's the engine here this
is only stop fish I don't have Houdini
in there at the moment the engine even
gives this as only slightly better for
black the saucer really strange rocket
III especially after exchanging now it
wants to play 98 this is interesting
night be a 27 this was a good maneuver
but positionally desirable but still
rocky 3 I completely ignored the p3 idea
and now Quincy five is good making sure
it exchanged and no yeah kingi 7s
babysit all right but this is just over
completely over and then you blundered
the Stooges remove any any normal move
wings here basically be 30 whatever i'm
just an exchange down and yet so it's
questionable if white is even
better I don't think so the the double
points are really am not much of a thing
here maybe there's some way to make
progress but this is of this of course
completely dead black and just stay here
and just wait yeah well I really let him
do everything that you wanted yep yeah
thanks for watching